good afternoon everybody
good afternoon we just witnessed a very
moving and inspiring an important event
I have lost my voice that's very good so
I will not say too many words I'm very
happy that we have with us
Commissioner akiaki new and vice
presidents yes we will share a few words
with you thank you all thank you for
being here I think we don't need many
words to describe what we just witnessed
this was a unique unprecedented event a
memorable occasion an emotional moment
that testifies our willingness to
mobilize everything we've got to make a
new start in fighting cancer as I said
inside very often Europe is perceived as
the aggregate of rules buildings people
technicalities but what we have just
seen now is another Europe a Europe that
can activate inspire mobilize pull
resources to make a difference and I
want to once again salute the work of my
colleague and dear friend Stella give a
Akitas but also our president also
underlined many others who put this
fight at the heart of the work of this
commission I think that's enough
thank you coming out of that room I
think we all felt the same emotion and
that was the energy and the level of
commitment that everyone here today was
part of this energy and commitment is a
commitment of the president of the
Commission of the commissioners and we
are all part of this joint effort with
all stakeholders with patience with
citizens with member states to produce a
Europe beating cancer plant today is the
beginning of a journey but it's a
journey that we're all going to work
together so I don't want to just thank
everyone for being here today
I can only say that we are committed and
have prioritized to put this plant first
to put citizens first and to look at the
right of cancer patients across our
member states as a priority I need to
before ending thank vice president
Margaret asinus who has been a huge
pillar of support for myself throughout
the preparation for this event and we're
going to be working on this together so
thank you very much for being here and
thank you very much for all the
commitment and energy that each and
every one of you put into the work every
day on beating cancer thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much thank you thank you